this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by the curiosity stream a
nebula bundle deal sign up now to watch
the hour-long version of this video
linked in the description
jet engines are a marvel of engineering
from precisely controlling the internal
atomic structure of metals to create
turbine blades that are actually one
single crystal to delicate robotic
machining that humans could only have
dreamed of a decade ago
the jet engines of today are barely
recognizable to those of the 1940s
they're bigger they're more powerful and
they're more efficient the dreamliner's
engines are so big that they are the
same diameter as the 737 fuselage and
this is just part of the puzzle that has
allowed the 787 dreamliner to break
world records
in march 2020 in the midst of a global
pandemic the us government imposed
travel restrictions on all european
travelers a move that cut off france
from one of its far-flung territories in
french polynesia
business as usual for air tahiti was no
more a creative solution had to be found
to replace their regular flights between
tahiti international airport and charles
de gaulle airport which under normal
circumstances stopped over in lax faced
with disruption air tahiti began
operating the world's longest flights a
16 and a half hour 15
700 kilometer non-stop flight between
tahiti and paris the world's longest
distance scheduled flight and it was
technically a domestic flight
the 787 made that possible and today we
are going to learn how
in our last video we explored the
incredible engineering that has gone
into sculpting the airframe of the 787
but all of that work is useless without
a power system to match
boeing transformed the way airliners are
powered to create a plane like no other
the first step in powering a large plane
is to get the jet engine started and
that itself is a very power hungry
process we need to get the compressor
section turning in order to achieve
adequate compression for engine ignition
we have all seen footage of people hand
cranking old piston-powered planes to
get them started this obviously is not
feasible for jet engines which need to
rotate at very high speeds to start
engineers have dreamed up many ways to
complete this job
some engines use explosive cartridges
that look like shotgun shells that will
be fired by an electric charge the hot
gas is expelled by the cartridge then
drive a smaller turbine which is
connected to the drive shaft through a
reduction gear allowing the smaller
turbine to get the engines up to speed
cartridge starters were popular in older
military planes that may need to get
into the air on very short notice with
limited ground support
some planes like the sr-71 had a direct
drive starting cars which connected two
massive v8 engines directly to the j58
engine from underneath the nacelle to
get the powerful jet engines up to 4500
rpm
however air starting is by far the most
common method where pressurized air is
fed into the turbine section directly to
get the engine moving this can be done
with an external cart called a hovercart
which connects hoses to the engine but
most commercial airliners are capable of
generating their own pressurized air
with an apu or auxiliary power unit
these are smaller turbine engines
located at the tail of the aircraft that
are small enough to get started with a
battery and an electric motor most
people aren't even aware this mini
turbine engine exists but you can see
the exhaust here on all modern
commercial airliners the 787s apu like
other planes is started by a small
battery but from here the 787 system
architecture is very different
the 787s apu like other planes is
started by a small battery but from here
the 787 system architecture is very
different
the 787s apu does not provide
pressurized air to the engines it
provides electric current to two
electric motors attached to each engine
which act like the starter motors on
your car
however these motors can act as
generators to provide the 787 with
unparalleled electric power
a traditional plane has one generator on
each engine and one on the apu but the
787 is anything but traditional there
are in total six generators on board
with two pairs on each engine providing
the main power each capable of
generating 250 kilowatts with two more
on the apu providing secondary power
each capable of providing
225 kilowatts
if all six of these generators were
running at the same time that would be
1.45 megawatts of power available to the
787
four times more than a triple seven is
capable of producing to put that into
perspective this is a 787 on a football
field if we needed to generate that
electricity with solar panels in the
middle of the day we would need to cover
about 10 football fields with solar
panels
this is a lot of power so why did the
787 need that much power and where is it
all going
the 787 uses a no bleed air architecture
traditionally many aircraft systems are
powered by hot compressed air drawn from
the compressor section of the jet engine
the apu normally provides hot air to the
engines to get them started and then
once the main engines are started hot
compressed air bled from the compressor
section drives several important systems
normally air conditioning and cabin
pressurization is handled by the bleed
air system the bleed air would be drawn
from the engine at a temperature upwards
of 230 degrees celsius this obviously
would quickly turn the cabin into an
oven
so the air would first run through a
complicated air conditioning and
pressurization system where some of the
air is cooled using a heat exchanger
which uses outside air from a surface
mounted intake called ram intakes to
remove heat from the engine bleed air
until it is a suitable temperature to be
distributed through the cabin so we are
doing work to remove energy from this
valuable bleed air from the engine
this is obviously rather inefficient and
all that ducting is heavy
and this is why the 787 does not use the
system its cabin pressurization is
handled entirely electrically we now
have two inlets the ram air inlet and
the cabin air compressor inlet
the cabin air compressor leads to you
guessed it the cabin air compressor an
electrically driven device that
compresses the air for the passenger
cabin this compression process heats the
air up too much for direct use into the
cabin so it does require some cooling
using a heat exchanger cooled by the ram
air inlet you can see this little door
open while the plane is on the ground
and it serves to protect the inlet from
foreign objects entering it
another energy intensive process that
has been handed over to the electric
motors is the braking system
as you can imagine the energy required
to slow down a 200 ton plane traveling
at 270 kilometers per hour is not small
calculating the energy required is
pretty trivial we just need to calculate
the kinetic energy of the object which
we can do with this equation and that
gives us a kinetic energy of
562 million joules that's a lot of
energy and the vast majority of that
energy needs to be dissipated by the
brakes of the plane reverse thrusters
can deploy that redirect air from the
bypass ducts through slots that open on
the side of the engine
so the brakes need to convert a lot of
kinetic energy into another form of
energy heat energy you can really see
this in effect during a plane's most
extreme brake test an aborted landing
test
here the plane is flying at full load
including the weight of the fuel and has
to abort at its v1 speed the absolute
maximum speed a plane can abort a
landing at
beyond that point the plane has to take
off when the plane comes to a full stop
the brakes are glowing red hot
typically the braking mechanisms of
planes is driven by hydraulics with a
hydraulic piston forcing the brake pads
against the wheel to slow down the plane
the 787 removed this bulky hydraulic
system and traded it in for brakes
actuated by electric motors
each of the eight landing gear wheels
feature one of these units and together
they helped eliminate between 62 to 111
kilograms of weight from the 787 while
also being drastically easier to
maintain and install the 787 does have a
hydraulic system however but it has
eliminated two large bleed air driven
hydraulic pumps that are normally used
to meet peak demand during takeoff and
landing where landing gear actuation and
deployment of high lift devices like
slats and flaps would overload the other
pumps that powered the hydraulic system
during cruise
the 787 had the added electric power
needed to rid itself of these bleed air
powered pumps and replaced them with
more efficient electrically driven pumps
to boot the 787 is able to generate
higher hydraulic pressures that allow it
to use smaller hydraulic components
which saves both weight and space
so that covers most of the system
architecture but we haven't even touched
on the revolutionary engines themselves
the dreamliner is most commonly fitted
with two general electric ge and x
engines each capable of producing
between 310 kilonewtons and 360
kilonewtons of thrust
about the same trust that general
electric's previous generation engines
the cf6 equipped to the 767 were capable
of producing but the ge nx produces this
trust while consuming 15 percent less
fuel
that's an incredible leap in technology
the ge nx achieves this primarily
through two major design features that
were not possible with older engines the
first is a gigantic bypass duct that
surrounds the main engine
the primary components of modern day jet
engines are the fan a compressor a
combustor a turbine and a nozzle the
ultimate goal of a jet engine is to draw
in air and pressurize it as much as
possible which increases the energy
potential of the air before mixing it
with fuel and igniting it causing a
rapid expansion and acceleration of air
the work done by the compressor is then
recovered in the turbine section which
powers both the compressor and the fan
finally the air with its remaining
kinetic energy travels through the
nozzle where it is accelerated more and
sent out the back of the engine to
provide thrust
the engine core this part of the engine
is what powers the engine yet most of
the air that travels through the genx
bypasses this section completely only
passing through the fan and through this
bypass duct and this is one of the
reasons the engine is so incredibly
efficient
bypass ratios have continually increased
over the years which is one of the
reasons engines keep getting bigger the
genx engine has a bypass ratio of 9 to 1
meaning for every kilogram of air that
passes through the engine core
nine kilograms flow through the bypass
duct
this is extremely high
the engine the genx replaced only had a
bypass of 5.7 which during its time was
itself a very high bypass ratio while
the core takes a small volume of air and
accelerates it rapidly the fan takes a
massive volume of air and accelerates it
just a little while not requiring it to
be mixed with fuel and ignite it this
drastically increases the fuel
efficiency of the plane the fan
essentially acts like a gigantic
propeller
the industry has been aiming for larger
and larger bypass ratios for decades but
there are a couple of limiting factors
that make it difficult to increase the
size of the fan blades
the compressor and fan are driven by the
same shaft meaning they rotate at the
same speed but because the fan is so
much larger than the compressor and
turbine blades the fan experiences much
higher centrifugal forces and if the fan
blades grow too long their tips could
even break the speed of sound leading to
shock waves and a massive increase in
drag the first problem we need to
address is how to handle those
centrifugal forces
the magnitude of the centrifugal force
can be found using this equation where m
is the mass w is the angular velocity
and r is the distance from the center of
rotation so our force will increase with
the weight of the blade the speed of its
rotation and its diameter we want to
increase our diameter to increase our
bypass ratio so we need to figure out
ways to either decrease our weight or
decrease our rotational speed
the ge and x achieved the first
requirement by using lightweight carbon
fiber fan blades
older fan blades were constructed from
titanium titanium being used for its
excellent strength to weight ratio
but carbon fiber blades have an even
higher strength to weight ratio while
also being much stiffer than titanium
allowing the carbon fiber composite
blades to be longer and thinner than
their titanium counterparts
this form factor even allowed general
electric to reduce the blade count from
22 to 18.
in all this resulted in a 15 weight
savings in the blades allowing them to
spin faster without worry of damage
however composites do have one huge
drawback their impact resistance
one of the tests engine need to pass to
reach certification is the chicken gun
test which as you may have guessed
involves eating a dead bird into the
engine and seeing how it holds up
the fan blades are the first part of the
engine any foreign object will encounter
and thus need to be capable of
withstanding the impact
early development of composite fan
blades by nasa and ge
showed that composite blades by
themselves simply were not up to the
task to solve the issue the leading edge
of the blades are reinforced with
titanium
bypass ratios are likely to continue
growing as our technologies develop
speed reduction gears between the main
driveshaft and the fan may allow engine
manufacturers to increase bypass ratios
even more
pratt and whitney employed this
technology in their pw1000g engine to
achieve the largest bypass ratio ever
seen in a commercial airline turbofan
engine they included a planetary gear
between the main driveshaft and the
turbofan driveshaft
which applied a three to one reduction
in speed allowing the turbofan to spin
at a lower four to five thousand rpm
this enabled the fan to grow in diameter
as the forces the larger blades had to
endure were drastically reduced with a
lower speed
giving the engine a record-breaking
12.5 to 1 bypass ratio
general electric considered the design
for their new leap engine currently in
use by the 737 max
but problems with weight and maintenance
of the planetary gearbox deterred them
and that hesitance may have been
justified as the engines have had a
turbulent operation history with several
groundings and engine removals although
these issues were not directly a result
of the planetary gears
however as the technology improves we
may see more of these geared designs
being used to drive even greater fuel
savings
the next design feature that helps the
genx to reduce fuel consumption is the
extremely high compression ratio
achieved through the engine's compressor
section
compression ratio is the ratio found by
dividing the pressure at the exit of the
compressor section by the pressure at
the inlet
this one variable has huge implications
for a plane's fuel efficiency
and just as we can see a clear upwards
trend for bypass ratios over time the
same can be seen for pressure ratios
the reason for this is fairly simple by
increasing the pressure ratio we can
maximize the energy we can extract from
our fuel because there is more useful
energy available for extraction in our
turbine and nozzle than if we compress
the air less
but it's not quite as easy as just
increasing pressure across our
compressor in order to achieve higher
compression we may need to increase the
number of compressor sections which will
increase the weight of the engine which
will increase fuel consumption and
reduce the advantage higher compression
will also lead to higher temperatures
which may cause material failure in the
compressor blades and perhaps most
critically increasing the temperature
results in increased emissions of potent
greenhouse gases
like nitrogen oxides
nitrogen oxide formation rates rise
exponentially with flame temperature to
break down nitrogen molecules in the air
and allow them to combine with oxygen to
facilitate increased pressure ratios
while hitting climate change goals this
problem had to be addressed and they did
it through ingenious fuel injection
technology the compressor feeds its high
pressure air into 22 fuel mixing nozzles
located in a ring around the compressor
exit
their job is fairly simple mix the fuel
into the air and ignite it
a simple job that started development in
1995
with both general electric and nasa
the art of crafting the perfect fuel
injection nozzle is incredibly complex a
delicate yet violent process like an
orchestra whose crescendo is a fiery
explosion with the advent of 3d printed
manufacturing ge has been able to create
a fuel injector with a complex internal
labyrinth of air channels that
traditional tooling simply could not
cause the fuel injector they developed
is called the twin annular pre-swirl
injector or taps
so how does it avoid those dangerous
nitrous oxide emissions
by carefully controlling the air fuel
mixture ratios to control flame
temperatures
if we plot flame temperatures against
air fuel ratio we get something that
looks like this the max flame
temperature is occurring at stokeometric
air fuel mixtures that is the mixture
where air and fuel are both entirely
consumed in the reaction
this is the zone where nitrous oxide
emissions are highest because the flame
temperature is highest to minimize
nitrous oxide emissions we can aim to be
over on this side of the curve with a
rich air fuel mixture but that would
result in a lot of wasted unburnt fuel
so instead we aim to be over here on the
lean side of the graph if we map the
combustion process for ge's previous
injector fitted to over 22 000
cfm-56 engines we would see the air fuel
mixture is initially injected in this
zone with a rich air fuel mixture
then it goes through a dilution process
to reach a lean mixture where the fuel
is fully consumed the issue with this is
that the fuel goes through the
stokeometric region in between these two
phases creating a great deal of nitrous
oxides
the taps fuel injector looks like this
with the central main pilot surrounded
by a ring-shaped main injector creating
two swirling airflows that looks
something like this which uses a large
amount of air in the pre-mixing phase to
ensure thorough mixing and a lean air
fuel mixture if we map the combustion
process of taps it starts in the lean
zone and gets even leaner further into
the combustor never getting close to the
peak nitrous oxide production region
this may seem like a simple device but
it took generations of design iterations
with computer simulations gradually
bringing the engineers closer to their
target and none of their designs would
have been possible without current
generation metallic 3d printing that
could manufacture the complex parts with
the materials capable of resisting the
enormous heat within the combustor 26
years of development paid off with 60
nitrous oxide emission reductions a fuel
injector compatible with a
record-breaking 58 to 1 pressure ratio
used in the genx
ge managed to increase the pressure
ratio even though they reduced the
number of compressor stages each of
these turbine disks is one stage the
genx contains 10 stages for fewer than
the cf6 engine it is replacing
ge managed to do this through new
improved blade design which is a lot
less info than i wanted to share but
finding information on this topic was
incredibly difficult a testament to how
advanced and secretive the technology is
the compressor does include three blisk
stages which are perhaps the most
impressive feats of machining i have
ever seen
traditionally compressor stages are made
by attaching the blades to a separate
disc with dovetail connections
this decreases manufacturing complexity
but the dovetail connection is less
durable increases assembly and
maintenance costs and allows some air to
escape through the connections
blisks are compressor stages that are
manufactured from a single piece of
metal making them stronger and easier to
install while improving aerodynamic
efficiency
improving aerodynamic efficiency was the
name of the game to improve compression
ratios and of course that needed to
apply to the turbine section that powers
the compressor it too benefited from
cutting edge aerodynamic modeling the
turbine also made use of new material
science breakthroughs being the first
commercial engine to make use of gamma
titanium alumini an advanced alloy of
titanium and aluminium that combines the
heat resistance of titanium with
aluminium's weight savings replacing the
nickel alloys of past
it took three decades to take this
material from the lab to commercial use
and the dreamliner was the first plane
to make use of it paving the way for the
materials acceptance in the industry
all of these factors combined to allow
the ge and x engines of the dreamliner
to reduce fuel consumption by 15
over previous generation engines
that is an astronomical leap and on top
of all that the engine is 60 quieter
than similar sized planes
in part thanks to the engine's most
distinctive feature this sawtooth
pattern on the fan casing and the engine
exhaust
these features are called engine
chevrons and they aren't just futuristic
cosmetic design
but functional parts of the engine that
significantly reduce engine noise
the question is what difference can a
mere shape change at a nozzle exit have
on the overall noise pollution produced
by the aircraft
because turbofan engines force air out
of their bypass chambers and turbines at
speeds that are much higher than the
speed of the ambient air the air
interacts with the free stream air
causing mixing this mixing causes
uncontrolled vortices which in turn
generate excessive noise for both the
passengers and the community on the
ground
think of it like water accelerating down
a waterfall and striking the water below
that turbulence can be extremely loud
the chevrons aim to control the vortices
that are shed from the engine nozzle by
creating smaller vortices at each of the
teeth of the chevron to allow the hot
fast air being expelled from the engine
to mix with the ambient air more gently
this is said to reduce jet blast noise
by as much as 30 percent and allowed
boeing to use substantially less sound
insulation in the fuselage walls of the
aircraft which helped to reduce aircraft
weight
the 787 truly does live up to its name
it provides a passenger experience that
is almost incomparable to that of other
commercial aircraft with advances in
noise reduction fuel efficiency and
passenger comfort
this series is usually saved for
aircraft and technology most of us will
never set foot in but the 787 could be
the most advanced piece of engineering
we've ever covered and it's a plane many
of us will have the opportunity to fly
in and marvel at the decades of
engineering advancements that made it
possible
this nearly half hour long video is just
half the story
but the full hour-long director's cut
version has been available on nebula for
over a week
it combines the two halves of this video
released on youtube into one seamless
ad-free experience that you can sit back
and relax to watch i removed one section
from this video detailing the
complicated thermodynamics explanation
of why compression ratios actually
increase efficiency because it felt just
too academic for youtube but i think
die-hard fans of this channel may enjoy
listening to a 10-minute explanation of
temperature entropy diagrams the
director's cut also includes
explanations of the 787s nifty
electronic heads-up display in the
cockpit and electrochromic window shades
i felt neither of these topics really
fit in anywhere in the larger script
nebula is the best way to experience our
videos no ads no distractions and
directors cuts of videos when possible
along with exclusive access to our world
war ii series the logistics of d-day and
our upcoming battle of britain series if
you want to see more content like this
the best way to support the channel is
by signing up to nebula with the
curiosity stream bundle i've included a
link to the director's cut in the
description for those of you already
subscribed to nebula or if you've yet to
start supporting the channel there you
can sign up through the nebula and
curiosity stream bundle deal for just
14.79 a year that's over one dollar a
month but that one dollar has a gigantic
impact on this channel because we get to
own and run our own streaming platform
and that gives us the freedom to create
what we want how we want
a little over one dollar a month this is
by far the best way to support this
channel and get something in return with
access to both nebula and all the
amazing award-winning documentaries on
curiosity stream like this one called
hack the moon about the fascinating
technologies engineers developed for the
apollo moon mission you can sign up to
this amazing deal by clicking on this
button on screen right now or if you are
looking for something else to watch
right now you could watch our last video
on how vapor cones form on planes
or you could watch real science's latest
video on how be communication is helping
us learn about the human brain